[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
enseignants enrayer la crise du
recrutement
et s'il n'y avait bientôt plus assez de
profs en france
en chute libre depuis 15 ans le nombre
de candidats aux concours de
l'enseignement ne fournit plus un vivier
suffisant pour recruter des professeurs
qualifiés
dans le même temps les démissions en
particulier de jeunes enseignants ont
triplé
dès lors comment anticiper le risque de
pénurie de professeurs qualifiés
pour répondre à cette question le
sénateur gérard longuet rapporteur
spécial de la mission enseignement
scolaire pour la commission des finances
a présenté son rapport le 9 juin 2022
les recommandations de son rapport
s'articule autour de trois axes
renforcer les moyens financiers pour
soutenir les professeurs réorienter la
gestion des ressources humaines et
développer les capacités d'analysé et de
prospective au sein de l'éducation
nationale
afin d'identifier les bonnes pratiques
le rapporteur a examiné en particulier
le système allemand caractérisée par des
rémunérations élevées et une complète
décentralisation et le système portugais
qui tend à renforcer l'autonomie des
établissements
les enseignants français après cinq ans
d'études supérieures souffre d'une
rémunération très faible dans les
premières années de leur carrière en
comparaison de leurs collègues européens
l'auteur du rapport plaide ainsi pour la
poursuite de la hausse des salaires pour
les professeurs débutants
il suggère par ailleurs d'étudier les
possibilités juridiques permettant la
mise en place d'une bonification de la
rémunération pour les enseignants dans
les disciplines et les territoires où le
déficit de professeurs est le plus
important
pour donner des résultats cet effort
financier doit s'inscrire dans le cadre
d'une refonte de la gestion de carrière
des professeurs justifie l'auteur du
rapport
il propose ainsi de s'inspirer d'autres
expériences européennes pour développer
l'auto évaluation des enseignants et
surtout leur évaluation par des pairs
pour améliorer l'accompagnement et le
perfectionnement des professeurs gérard
longuet souhaite par exemple que l'offre
de formation continue ciblent davantage
les thèmes disciplinaires et de gestion
de classe
enfin le rapporteur spécial préconise de
développer les capacités d'analysé et de
prospective au sein du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et de mettre en
place un service dédié aux comparaisons
internationales
au delà du traitement et de la
production de statistiques
pour en savoir plus consultez les quinze
recommandations du rapport
[Musique]